we shouldn't have to know his name we
shouldn't have to be commemorating him
we shouldn't have to be drawing
comparison emmett till
because george floyd should still be
alive
but here we are exactly one year after
this father
this brother was murdered by a
minneapolis police officer a civil
servant sworn
to protect him the george floyd memorial
foundation held a celebration
of life event in minneapolis featuring
speakers
art and a moment of silence that lasted
9 minutes
and 29 seconds how long the convicted
police officer knelt on george floyd's
neck
as floyd pleaded for his life and
agitated onlookers yelled
for the officer to stop today
floyd's loved ones gathered in
washington dc they met
privately with president biden as well
as with speaker nancy pelosi and
congresswoman karen bass
they pushed congress to pass the george
floyd
the george floyd justice and policing
act which joe biden had hoped
to have on his desk to sign today
we will get this bill on the desk and
what is important is
that when it reaches president biden's
destination piece of legislation
and that is far more important than a
specific
date we need it on body we need to get
this taken care of
because just like gianna said
your
[Applause]
and some things have changed in the year
since george floyd's murder
the massive nationwide protests we saw
demanded changes in policing and racial
inequality
and awakening across multiple sectors of
our society and in some places that did
lead to action
according to the brennan center 30
states enacted police reform legislation
in the year since floyd's death those in
the dark blue specifically addressed use
of force
an officer's duty to stop another
officer or reporting misconduct
corporations committed to increasing
diversity and fighting racism
and as one journalist told politico
magazine the phrase systemic racism
went from a conversation stopper to a
mainstream conversation
starter practically overnight but we
shouldn't have needed
george floyd or anyone to die for all of
that to happen
and let's be clear his life was taken he
didn't
give himself to the cause as some have
suggested
thank you george floyd for sacrificing
your life for justice
your name will always be synonymous with
justice
but he wasn't trying to sacrifice his
life nor should he have had to
in fact he begged for his life cried out
to his mother with his last breaths
murdered on camera for the whole world
to see
our country sadly has a long history of
witnessing black death
lynchings were shared on postcards from
slavery through jim crow many of those
lynchings were public affairs
now we have cell phones and the deaths
of black americans often at the hands of
police
captured on video are sadly all too
common
spread around not only the nation but
the world
look i get it we want to remember george
floyd and celebrate his life
he deserves our remembrance but black
americans should not have to die and
then become hashtags on mass
to enact change especially the kind
that's long lasting
and yes systemic to many such change
remains
elusive despite the historic protests
the moves by
local officials to reform police despite
a president who's putting racial justice
at the forefront
we also have this 967 people shot
and killed by police in the past year
and it may come
as no surprise that they are
disproportionately black
elle chris stewart is the ceo of stuart
miller-simmons trial attorneys where
justin miller is also a partner
together they served as co-lead counsel
to george floyd's family
during that difficult historic trial of
former police officer derek shovin who
was found guilty of murder
gentlemen thank you both for joining me
tonight uh chris let me start with you
how is the family doing today one year
after they lost george floyd
a lot better than they were a year ago i
mean today was actually a day of uplift
this family was involved in meetings
from the president on down to senators
to representatives that it's historic
and they actually wanted their input
they wanted our input
there was these sense of change on both
sides that
it's going to happen the bill will
happen
yes uh and i'll come back to that bill
in a moment just in the family met with
president biden and vice president
harris at the white house
uh have a listen to what george floyd's
brother philonous said let's listen to
what he said after the meeting
if you can make federal laws to protect
the bird
which is the bald eagle you can make
federal laws to protect people of color
so justin what was the family's message
to the president and vice president
today specifically
yeah um i think the family's message was
that change can happen and it's going to
take both sides of the aisle to make it
happen
uh the family's ready to get some
closure but that can't happen for them
because this is so big in this case
really encompasses the whole world it
can't happen for them
until this bill is passed so i think the
family is glad that
people are listening on both sides of
the aisle but um
they're ready to get some real healing
and um to try to you know get this past
them and move forward
and chris you also spoke after that
white house meeting and recounted
a rather tender moment between the
president and george floyd's daughter
gianna
let's have a listen president actually
interacted and played with gianna she
had an absolute ball
and that's why this may be a sad day
across the country but this was a
super happy day seeing her smile like
she's still smiling
so if everybody can just come together
democrat democrat republican
and pass the bill if you care about
policing and the people it will get
passed
in terms of passing the bill as you know
chris the president hoped to have the
george floyd justice and policing act on
his desk
to sign by today the anniversary of the
killing
negotiations on the bill are still
ongoing and the president says he
doesn't want a rushed bill he wants the
right bill
are you confident that lawmakers on both
sides can come to a substantive deal one
that actually enacts
much-needed reform
you know i know he said a deadline that
he wanted it today but you have to
understand
they're up against a lot of unions there
it gets a lot of outside pressure
to come to a deal to come to some kind
of reform and i understand a lynchpin
may be
uh qualified immunity but you have to
also look at all of the other stuff in
the bill
that will stop black people from being
killed i understand qualified immunities
to allow a lawsuit
after someone's been killed but we want
us to not even have to go to that point
we want to stop policing uh bad policing
so people aren't dying so let's get the
bill passed let's
tweet qualified immunity and get rid of
it and and get the reform we needed
but the real substantial parts will stop
us
from ever needing to get stepped
and chris one of the big sticky boys you
mentioned qualified immunity
uh holding police officers accountable
in civil suits senator tim scott
the lead republican in these
negotiations has offered what he says is
a compromise
that would allow people to sue police
departments rather than individual
police officers over civil rights
violations
where do you stand on that and dare i
ask where does the floyd family stand on
that
i get it i understand it because what
you know what the compromise is what
people are trying to understand
how do you stop bad officers or how do
you stop bad behavior
departments have no incentive right now
to check their officers
or stop their bad behavior because
they're not liable
they're not responsible they just fire
the officer you can sue them and you
could have the cop
but now departments will be on the line
and i guarantee you police chiefs
are not going to be messing around
anymore when their department
can be sued
that's a very good point um justin
excuse me i've got something in my
throat
excuse me justin derek shoving was
convicted of floyd's murder last month
three other officers who did not stop
him
are awaiting trial that was supposed to
start in august but a judge delayed that
trial to next year after new
federal charges were filed against all
four officers
what's next in this legal battle
well like you said those three officers
have to make a choice
the country has spoken minnesota has
spoken the people have spoken and
this is not going to be tolerated in our
communities any longer
so those three officers have to make a
choice as to whether they want to go to
trial and and try their luck
or if they want to take a plea so that's
the next step then the next step for us
for all of us who are not on trial
is to try to get this act passed the
george floyd
justice and policing act passed because
it's going to go a long way
into stopping this from happening
happening again you said something
earlier
uh that was really poignant you said
george floyd did not give his life his
life was taken
he did not choose to be a martyr he is
not um
jesus christ george floyd was killed and
murdered
and we have to stop this and this act is
going to go a long way in
helping to stop it it won't be the only
deterrent but it will be a big one
and we have to keep pushing for it
justin as you say his life was taken it
was taken by derek
chauvin what are you expecting uh in
terms of derek chovin's sentencing next
month
um well we think that derek shoving is
going to see a lot of years behind bars
we can't really talk about you know what
the judge is going to do
but there are a lot of factors that went
in that came into play during the trial
that will elevate the sentencing and
hopefully keep him in jail for a very
long time
and chris and justin both of you one
more question for both of you before we
go
you've obviously been closely involved
in this case
as lawyers for the family but can i ask
you both not as two lawyers but as two
black men in america what does george
floyd mean to you
change uh it's exactly what gianna said
when she was on
stephen jackson's shoulder said my daddy
changed the world
um we've been dealing with these cases
forever i mean all the way back to
walter scott which we thought would
change the world
and a lot of other cases this is the
first time in history
that civil rights is being discussed not
just by black people of
our white hispanic asian everyone in the
world
and change is right on the horizon um
and we just gotta keep pushing for it
that's what this case is that's what
george floyd has stood for
and and to me it means that someone is
finally listening
eyes are finally opening ears are
finally opening
to hear what's going on to people in
this country um some people
are immune to this some people don't see
this just based on where they live or
the people they know
so i think that the pandemic plus george
floyd allowed everyone to kind of see
what is happening to us their fellow
americans
and um as black men um we're glad
people's eyes are opening we hate it had
to be george floyd and his family to go
through it but we're glad people
are now listening and seeing
i mean you you put your finger on it
right there justin it's horrible that it
had to be george floyd
who was killed it's horrible that his
family had to go through it and now has
to go to the white house
and capitol hill to make this case um
but if we can prevent future george
floyd's as you say forget qualified
immunity let's not have
the killings in the first place
appreciate your work appreciate your
time gentlemen chris stewart
and justin miller attorneys for the
family of george floyd thank you so much
for appearing on the show tonight
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date
on the day's biggest stories thank you
for watching